die erste kolonie der menschheit im all
statt auf dem mars oder dem mond könnte
sich die zukunft der menschheit auf
einer raumstation abspielen und zwar im
orbit des zwergplaneten ceres der
finnische wissenschaftler pk ja nun hat
ein ausgefeiltes konzept für solche
siedlungen weltall erarbeitet und er ist
sich sicher das leben hier wäre deutlich
vorteilhafter als auf mond oder mars und
seiner ansicht nach sogar noch in diesem
jahrhundert umsetzbar
jetzt wird's spannend bei pixum science
in future.de gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen und auch das ist mega auf
spotify haben wir mit unserem podcast in
designs charts geschafft also weiter
fleißig abonnieren und natürlich hören
die dinge sind hier unter oder in der
video beschreibung oder im ersten an
geprägten kommentar schon ziemlich bald
werden wir menschen in den weltraum
besiedeln können
davon sind viele überzeugt die große
frage lautet nur welcher planet eignet
sich dafür am besten ihre masse setzt
beispielsweise alles auf dem mars aber
auch der mond ist mit im rennen als mond
natürlich doch manche fachleute sehen
eine ganz andere möglichkeit städte im
weltraum und zwar ganz unabhängig von
einem planetaren standort dazu gehört
auch der finnische wissenschaftler pk
jahren holen
er hat jetzt ein aktuelles papier
veröffentlicht mit einer wirklich
spannenden zukunftsvision er schlägt
einen mega satelliten um netzwerk
planeten cs vorstädte im weltraum also
quasi eine raumstation wie die
internationale raumstation iss nur in
wesentlich größerem ausmaß und seiner
meinung nach hätte solch ein weltraum
habitat gleich mehrere entscheidende
vorteile gegenüber der besiedlung eines
bestimmten himmelskörpers wie dem mars
oder die mohn konkret schlägt der einen
solchen mega satelliten im orbit des
zwergplaneten ceres vor also im
asteroidengürtel zwischen jupiter und
mars wie genau würde das leben der
menschheit hier aussehen und wie
realistisch sind die ideen von pk ja nun
wirklich die antworten auf all diese
spannenden fragen gibt es in diesem
video fest steht nicht nur die nasa und
die esa sondern auch china wollen zurück
auf den mond noch in diesem jahrzehnt
sollen wieder menschen dorthin fliegen
und auch für längere zeit dort bleiben
eine bemannte nasa mission könnte
möglicherweise schon im jahr 2024 auf
dem mond landen
und möglicherweise eine mondstation
beziehen als erster außenposten der
menschheit auf einem anderen
himmelskörper dazu der nasa
wissenschaftler den screen
geplant ist dass 2024 eine bemannte
landung auf dem mond stattfinden soll
das ziel ist die suche nach wasser das
auch für künftige mars-mission wichtig
ist die nasa hat die hoffnung das ende
der 30er jahre erstmals menschen auf dem
mars landen können das aufspüren von
wasser auf dem mond sein dafür ein
entscheidender meilenstein doch auch
unseren nachbarn planet der mars steht
im visier der fachleute schon seit
längerer zeit arbeiten forschende an den
plänen einer bemannten landung auf dem
roten planeten und einer kolonie vor ort
ganz vorne mit dabei fielen mast seines
zeichens chef von tesla und den weltraum
unternehmen spacex seiner überzeugung
zufolge kann lediglich eine autarke
statt auf dem roten planeten das
fortbestehen der menschheit sichern doch
es gibt einige herausforderungen und die
müssen zunächst bewältigt werden denn
das menschliche leben auf fremden
planeten wäre alles andere als ein
zuckerschlecken die probleme sind unter
anderem extremen temperaturen die harte
strahlung und auch meteoriteneinschläge
viele kompromisse also die die
menschheit bei solchen kleinen
standorten hinnehmen müsste viel zu
viele kompromisse sagt der finnische
wissenschaftler brega jan o er hat sich
gedanken dazu gemacht wie eine siedlung
im all konstruiert sein müsste um diesen
ganzen nachteilen aus dem weg zu gehen
der wissenschaftler hat ein paper
veröffentlicht in dem er ein konzept für
eine stadt im alt ziemlich detailliert
ausgearbeitet hat seiner meinung nach
könnte eine raumstation um den
zwergplaneten ceres die lösung sein eine
art mega satte liegt also im
asteroidengürtel zwischen mars und
jupiter und diese weltraum sieg könnte
man sich folgendermaßen vorstellen viele
dutzend zylinder die alle jeweils viele
kilometer groß werden jeder einzelnen
zylinder aber wäre auf ein und derselben
scheibe montiert die die verschiedenen
zylinder somit zusammenhält unter und
oberhalb der scheibe könnten
sonnenspiegel installiert werden die
diese weltraum siedlung bescheid
diese würden enorme vorteile mit sich
bringt sie könnten für einen tag nacht
rhythmus sorgen und so auch ackerbau
ermöglichen das ziel wäre also ein
ökologischer raum in dem nicht nur
menschen sondern auch pflanzen insekten
und vögel leben und in dem jedes atom
recycelt wird das ganze könnte nach
ansicht von pge hund dann sogar ziemlich
nachhaltig sein wenn alles was gebraucht
auch recycelt wird die nähe soziales
hätte den vorteil dass dieser die
materialien für den bau liefern könnte
zudem ist in manchen regionen an der
oberfläche von cs stickstoff zu finden
ein wichtiger baustein um eine ähnliche
atmosphäre zu verschaffen den es auf
anderen planeten oder monde so nicht
gibt heißt also im klartext dass wir
menschen laut dieser vision auf
raumschiffen mit der hilfe von
sonnensegeln durch das all transportiert
würden und das ganz ohne
raketentreibstoff die idee vom pkw ein
hund ist übrigens nicht ganz neu schon
vor 40 jahren hatte der us amerikanische
physiker juni ein ähnliches weltraum
sieht das konzept vorgeschlagen in
seinem buch sei frontier tjumen colonies
in space beschreibt er die vision der
sogenannten o'neal zylinder die jeweils
aus zwei zylindern bestehen die
gegenläufig rotieren
durch ein lager system verbunden könnten
sich diese so drehen dass die
zentrifugalkraft an den innenflächen
dafür sorgt dass eine künstliche
schwerkraft erzeugt wird auch innerhalb
des weltraum habitat das jahren hohen
vorschlägt wäre die gravitation so groß
wie auf der erde dazu sagt der finnische
wissenschaftler pkw hund in einem
interview in spektrum de wenn wir
wirklich eine millionen menschen auf dem
mars antiken bringt das ein großes
ethisches problem mit sich kinder werden
dort mit nur einem drittel der irdischen
schwerkraft aufwachsen was ihre körper
verändern dürfte vermutlich könnten
diese menschen nie zur erde zurückkehren
weil sie hier buchstäblich nicht mehr
aus dem bett kämen so lebenswert ist
dermaßen auch nicht viele mast ist die
colonia in erster linie eine art
notfallplan falls auf der erde etwas
schief geht aber wer will schon in einem
backup leben und dafür abstriche in der
lebensqualität machen über all das wird
leider viel zu wenig gesprochen
einen weiteren vorteil seiner idee sieht
ja nun darin dass wir uns mit einer
solchen weltraum siedlung ein echtes
zitat paradies erschaffen könnten
umweltbedingungen die wir auf der erde
sony haben werden er argumentiert dass
wir dort mit hilfe von spiegeln und
filtern die sonne so lenken können wie
wir es uns eben wünschen jahreszeiten
und extreme klimabedingungen wir auf der
erde müssen wir dort also nicht
befürchten genauso wenig müssen wir uns
in solch einer weltraum stadt sorgen vor
naturkatastrophen machen und die dicke
schutzhülle würde uns menschen vor der
gefährlichen weltraum strahlung und vom
mikrometeoriten schützen
im besten fall könnten wir uns menschen
also so ausbreiten ohne lebensräume zu
zerstören oder anderen
zu schaden oder uns selbst zu gefährden
dazu der finnische wissenschaftler im
interview mit spektrum de wir würden
einfach einen teil des freien platz ist
im universum mit leben füllen nach einem
großes staat investment könnte man damit
wahrscheinlich sogar geld verdient weil
man ein angebot geschaffen hat dass
vorher nicht da war
der mega satz liegt macht klein wirken
aber wir reden hier letztlich von einer
fläche die am ende größer sein könnte
als die erdoberfläche den analysen von
pkw um zur folge hätte hier jeder
einzelne mensch so viel platz derzeit
wie die menschen in den niederlanden
doch wie realitätsnah ist die saison
wirklich feststeht um solch ein weltraum
habitat zu erschaffen ist jede menge
material notwendig als das nämlich
achtung 10.000 tonnen material pro
person müssten ja außerdem auch noch ins
weltall transportiert werden bgh nun
schlägt hier roboter vor die vor ort
zunächst fabriken bauen würden damit die
ganzen rohmaterialien verarbeitet werden
können
mit hilfe eines weltraum aufzuges
aufzehren könnten diese dann nach oben
ins all gebracht werden da die
schwerkraft hier geringer ist könnten
jan hundes ansicht zufolge sogar stahl
oder carbonfasern ausreichen um ein
stabiles sei für den aufzug zu
garantieren das habe ich ja übrigens
auch in meinem buch per aufzug in den
weltraum geschildert hier auf der erde
schwierig auf dem mond oder jetzt eben
auch oft sehr es ziemlich einfach zu
bauen einen weltraum aufzogen dazu sagt
er im interview mit spektrum de
natürlich würde man in sachen weltraum
habe die tat nicht gleich mit einem
kilometer großen zylinder staaten man
würde zunächst eine kleine raumstation
mit künstlicher schwerkraft bauen
dort könnte man dann all die probleme
lösen die es noch gibt und irgendwann
hat man dann eine funktionierende
biosphäre die man hoch skalieren kann
großer fan dieser idee es beispielsweise
der amazon gründer jeff bezos er hatte
vor zwei jahren 2009/10 bei einer
veranstaltung vorgeschlagen genau solche
uni kolonien zu bauen und von der
besiedlung anderer planeten abstand zu
nehmen doch einige hürden sind noch
zunehmen und jan hunden ist offen dafür
dass weitere ideen einfließen und seine
idee weiter gedacht wird offen bleibt
beispielsweise die frage wie der
transport zwischen den einzelnen
habitaten ablaufen könnte also wirklich
spannend und das noch in diesem
jahrhundert also theoretisch möglich
auch unseren podcast gibt es übrigens
bereits in diesem jahrhundert anklicken
anhören und abonnieren
auch sehr gerne bei spotify bis dann
bleibt